these are three things you might not
know about Theo Von starting off with
his real name which is way more
complicated than it seems hit me with
the birth name cuz I read this and I was
I can't even say it Theodore Capitan Von
katowski Theo's real name isn't the only
surprising thing about him because fact
number two is that before he was a
comedian Theo Von used to do man on- the
street interviews with random people
going to events like golf tournaments
and ComicCon how does it feel to be
Steve from Minecraft it's so awesome um
it's really awesome interviewing
Minecraft characters isn't the only job
Theo had before comedy most people know
that Theo's first experience with
television happened on a reality TV show
called Road Rules what is surprising
however is that he sted alongside Tom
sora's now wife Christina Pete did you
feel upset that I didn't try to make any
moves on your wife no okay I
mean